foreign
[Music]
people as accomplished as either of you
I actually love to go back to the
beginning and ask what was your first
job in this business like were you
someone who started in you know the mail
room of an agency or where did it all
begin the glamor of it all
[Music]
right I don't even totally remember
because I when I was in college
I went to school in LA and arranged my
schedule to where I was finished for the
day by one o'clock and then I went and
interned in all you know many strange
corners of the business like for like
weird casting directors and Tiny shitty
agencies in the middle of nowhere and I
wrote like terrible online movie reviews
um so a bunch of sort of odd jobs like
online movie reviews for like a specific
site or sort of like I won't say the
site because if they are still running I
don't want to denigrate them publicly
I'm a very good googler I'm gonna have
to find those
um uh also hi again uh thank you for
staying with us um thanks for watching
it and thanks for no please thank you
but thanks for watching it and thanks
for sticking around to chat
um
I mean my first jobs were like
babysitting kids who didn't like me and
waitressing
um but um in the industry
um as I said earlier I'm I've primarily
been a theater director so my first jobs
um uh were in the literary departments
at a couple of regional theaters I grew
up in New York
um but I didn't want to go back to my
hometown right after school like many
people I felt sort of like haunted by
the ghost of my adolescent self
um so I worked in the literary
department at a theater called
Steppenwolf in Chicago and in the
literary department at yeah
um and in the literary department at um
a theater called Berkeley Rep out in the
Bay Area
um yeah fantastic did you always know it
was directing you wanted to do or yeah
from an early age
um were you did you direct plays as a
kid like or just boss people around
the latter yes
um no I mean what's actually funny is in
my house I have an older sister and we
it was she was the director I mean when
we were kids she would like make us you
know do things when the kids would
gather she was like a hide Piper with
little kids she was a leader and so she
was the director perhaps there's
something in that
um but um uh yeah I went to this
is that me no okay they're um uh I went
to this idiosyncratic public high school
in New York
where
um the students could direct the plays
and I for reasons unclear to me like
many people auditioned for the school
play as like a 12 year old and was
mostly cast as
um sort of old ladies and men
um and um he nods yeah exactly you see
it
um and um I know
uh I guess they call it a character
actor or something
um no I'm sorry um but yeah I was kind
of one of those bossy kids who wanted to
run whatever Club I was in and you could
direct the place so I directed for the
first time when I was 17. do you
remember the first show you directed it
was a it was a Comic Shorts by David
Ives and Chris durang oddly enough wow
Christopher durang at a young age even
yeah okay well we weren't allowed to
touch that stuff till I was like in my
20s it was it was Neil Simon or nothing
um so I would love to start at the
beginning with Causeway how did this
project find its way to you and what
interested you in being a part with it
and I don't know which one of you it
began with or if it came to you
simultaneously
I mean kind of simultaneously
um
um well for for my side of the story
um this project began in the spring of
2019.
um I had just opened a play a production
of Kenny lonergan's play the Waverly
gallery and um one of The Producers on
that project handed me the original
draft of this script
um and I um was very taken with it
immediately uh I attached myself to it
and only a few weeks later I found out
that Jen had read it and also had a very
strong reaction to it and I was asked
would I like to have dinner with her I
said yes
um and then we had dinner and um the
story really begins there I mean she
signed on that night and we were
actually in production only a few months
later wow and it's just that easy you
thought well yes and or something and
then we would sort of end up waiting two
years on the back end to complete it in
a global pandemic so um but the
beginning was quite serendipitous
for us
the script came in at the end of her
three-ish year Hiatus and she was being
very thoughtful about
the material she wanted to return with
and
as I'm sure you all know she did sort of
a barrage of bigger Studio films and I
think was craving something more
intimate and
this was a true character piece
I think at the time so much of what we
were reading was really sort of
traditionally structured and
like perfectly resolved and perfectly
Redemptive and this felt
more abstract and it lived in the
subtext and so that felt much more
relatable and
so she was she had like an immediate
reaction to that draft and then we found
out that Lila had read it probably maybe
a week before and so like she said they
got together in New York and made the
decision that night and I think we were
in New Orleans three months later wow it
came together very quickly uh such a
question I always wonder about
production companies how do you how do
you know what to read there's so much
coming in what made this one stand out
they heard what I just said like
particularly
um
so much of the writing that is being I
mean half of some of it is things are
submitted to us through agencies or
colleagues our networks and then of
course for us specifically we're finding
things ourselves in this case it was
submitted to us the original draft red
white and water and
as I said at the time we were reading
really sort of conventional work and
you could feel the Soul on the page
like I said it was messy it felt poetic
um
it was highly unique in general but
specifically at that time
just wondering what makes you know you
probably have so many choices what makes
something jump off the page I don't know
if there was a good log line or I I
think it was a combination of of I think
the timing for Jen it had been so long
as I said since she had since we had
seen her in
or I guess she read something where she
could have seen herself back in such a
stripped back mode it had been like over
a decade since she had done something
like that Winter's Bone being like the
obvious comp
um
I think she had a pretty deep personal
connection to the material
and
Lila meeting Lila and hearing Lila's
perspective and I think it's a
combination of a lot of things
and Lila you're you're obviously a very
clean theater director have you always
wanted to do film were you looking for
the right project to sort of make that
transition with
um
I mean in my heart uh I had always hoped
at some point to make
some movies before I die
um
um but I was not I would say like a lot
of Freelancers I was really living my
life one project at a time and
preoccupied with what I was doing and
interested in the work and and feeling
totally immersed in it and challenged by
it and staying curious in it
um but not long before I read this I had
begun saying out loud that I was
interested in working in other mediums
and had begun reading scripts and things
were being sent to me and I was sort of
sniffing things out and then
um very fortuitously read this and I
think not radically unlike Jen's
reaction
um found myself
kind of disarmed
by how deeply connected I felt to this
character's inner life upon reading this
I'm not a veteran I am not a member of
the Armed Forces
um but uh
yeah I felt recognition in encountering
this character and it was I would say
personalized for me very quickly it's
one of the things I love about this
movie because it's such a specific story
but it feels so Universal in so many
ways and I I know so many people have
seen it who relate to one of these
characters that on the surface you
wouldn't think they had anything in
common
I mean I'm glad that that's your sense
um I I would I would hope that's the
case
um I mean as you can see I had that
reaction myself to reading a much
earlier and and a different but I think
at core the the through line between
what I read then what we read then and
what you saw
um sound a little woo-woo but I would
say the soul of this film is the soul of
that document that I read
um
yeah and and I would also add that I
don't share life experience with him but
I feel connected to James Oakland's
inner life
very much so
um and I'm you know obviously Jennifer
is an amazing actress she can do
anything but what made her you know so
perfect for this role and and
to work with as a collaborator not just
only as an actor but as a producer
um
I'm like where to begin
um it has candidly been an unmitigated
joy to collaborate with Jen on this
project as an actor and as a producer
um
I find myself still
um marveling
uh I'm biased but I find myself
marveling at least in this performance
um in her capacity to convey such a raw
depth of feeling in such an understated
and restrained register I think there's
a discipline required in that that I
find particularly attractive in
performance and in her in her capacity
um uh and I've I have felt that in a lot
of her work even in cinematic registers
that feel louder or faster I think her
capacity for Stillness is is actually
quite extraordinary what she can command
in Stillness the kind of energetic force
field I mean screen presence it's such a
difficult thing to really articulate
adequately how it works to find language
that feels commensurate to our
experience of screen presence
um that's part of what makes it so
magical it's experience but I find that
the kind of
um the line of energy G between gen and
the lens and then to you or to me
watching it's taught
um you know in a very particularly
potent way
um and in terms of her collaboration as
a producer
um
you know along the way because she wore
multiple hats in this project people
have asked me like was that weird you
know were you working for her was she
working for you power dynamics and truly
um uh that thought it never occurred to
me because the feeling from the outset
very clearly was that we are working
together for the film uh for the best
film we can make together
um as a producer and I would say the
same about the woman sitting next to me
um I they are both real advocates for
the filmmaker you know this is my first
movie I think um I will confess I think
I have been spoiled
um working with producers who really see
their job as protecting the filmmaker
and advocating for what they're
attempting to do
um yeah period
and Justine for you what do you see your
job as a producer in helping the
filmmaker but also helping Jennifer so
that she can be an actor and do these
incredibly challenging scenes and you
can sort of you know watch the producing
side while she concentrates on that sure
I mean I think
and I believe from a produce orial
perspective Jim would say the same thing
to protect the process and to protect
Lila period
I think that's in large part why Jen
wanted to start the company I think that
Jen's artistic scope
exceeds what might make sense for her as
an actor and so this is a way for her to
support
a wider range of Storytelling but also
to have the ability to protect the
process and to protect a filmmaker
especially on a picture this small
it's exactly why you do it
and speaking of this cash you have the
amazing Brian Tyree Henry I did you go
to college with him I think I heard
wow so did you bring him to the table I
mean I don't think anyone would object
when when Brian is brought up in a
casting session
um yeah I've known Brian since I was 19.
I was an undergrad when he was he was in
grad school in drama school so
um I don't think it's much of a secret
but I feel like I've been in on the
secret for a long time so yeah I first
saw Brian in the plays of Lanford Wilson
and Terrell mccraney then I saw him do
Shakespeare in the park so I have known
for a very long time that he is an actor
of just unbelievable range and depth of
Spirit uh depth of humanity Integrity as
an actor as a person
um and um yes I read the script and I uh
he was the only person I wanted to play
this role and I continue to feel
genuinely humbled and ecstatic that he
wanted to be a part of my first movie
I mean so much of the movie hinges on
their relationship and their chemistry
um were they able to was there any kind
of a chemistry read did they meet in
person or when you someone's as good as
both of them you just know it's gonna
work
you hope yeah and you suspect I mean
also having met Jen and spent some a lot
of time with her and then knowing Brian
I had a I had a good feeling about it
but you also never know what's going to
happen when two people meet for the
first time and I think it was uh wildly
Apparent from their first encounter in
life that these two would have a strong
connection and I think from the first
moment seeing them on screen together
um
it was just like it was overwhelmingly
joyful
um the space between them is so alive
and um it really is a cliche but it's
like there's there are some things you
cannot fake you know
um and and um they're they're um Rapport
as human beings
um it's it's very alive in life as well
were you there when they met for the
first time I would love to know what
that was like
yeah I mean they just knew how to joke
with each other real fast real fast yeah
and I think also it was artists the way
they move is super similar when they're
in a work mode
they have like identical their flow I
would say deep agree and I would say
that both of them I think came to the
material feeling meaningfully connected
to each of their characters in our lives
and so I think they both came to this
project with tremendous skin in the game
and and real uh personal stakes in the
storytelling and
um we I was able to involve them in the
development of the script from an early
stage and that input was invaluable and
indispensable and meaningfully impacted
how the story unfolded
um and I think they're having those
kinds of personal Stakes is hugely
significant to the film that we wound up
with actually want to talk about the
development of the script because
something Justine mentioned earlier is I
love how much you learn through subtext
and how a lot isn't overtly stated uh
especially up front was there a
conscious decision to sort of hold back
on some of the information and let it
reveal itself
um
I would say
the very first draft of the screenplay
for this film that I read was already
characterized I would call it spare
that was present and I would also say
that there was I felt in it a kind of uh
a lyricism a deeply felt quiet spare
lyricism and what felt like an
invitation to a quiet and patient
poetry of some kind
um and I say poetry in the sense of
um
I mean not all poetry is concise but
much of it is in an attempt to allow
hopefully a little to say a lot more
um there was what I felt was an
invitation to a minimalist Sensibility
and a sensitivity in that minimalism
um but I would add
um that it's probably not
unrelated that there is material that we
shot for this film that might have
fleshed out certain aspects of the film
that I removed from the film
um most notably perhaps flashbacks
and that was a process and I think part
of what was revealing itself to me in
that process
um had to do with
um
in part trusting the performances
to speak volumes
and also I'm like what is happening
what's happening someone's having a good
time it's a wedding like what are we
doing here should we crash free bar
after this
um sorry there's um
what's weird about it is that it just
sounds like one person
it's like that person's having a great
wedding
um sorry
um
it's fair uh suggestive scenes oh yes
um uh I also felt very blessed on this
film to work with actors and I want to
acknowledge in addition to to Jen and
Brian
um you know every member of The
Supporting Cast in this film is someone
that I knew from the New York theater
Community who I yeah who I'd either
worked on plays with or seen in plays on
Broadway and Off-Broadway and some of
the gifts that those actors happened to
share Linda Eamon Jane how do you shall
Stephen McKinley Henderson is that these
are people who I I think in significant
part due to their life in the theater
where you build up a great deal of um
circumstantial information that you're
drawing from they are actors who have a
remarkable capacity to draw inference
and extrapolation from
um the most suggestive
line of dialogue and so the ability to
work with people who were fleshing out
their characters in our lives and the
kind of tapestry of supporting
information around what they said I
think also emboldened me to lean into
um that let's say minimalism in a number
of different respects I mean when your
movie opens with Jane had a shell you
know you're in good hands actually I
think I've been mispronouncing it all
these years I always thought it was who
to Shell
um well I don't I think Jane wouldn't
object to that pronunciation I don't
think but it's howdy show yeah I was I
would I would defer to you
the film also it just feels so authentic
and real and raw I'm curious um how you
brought such of this author sent it
authenticity
um to the script and then once you get
to set to those performances to the
atmosphere
I guess I would
having a few different thoughts I would
start by saying that the project of
authenticity
in this particular project began for me
with the awareness upon reading that
first draft we keep referring to that I
couldn't and wouldn't make this film
without meaningfully consulting with
people who had lived this experience so
I had the opportunity to consult at
Great length with U.S Department of
Veteran Affairs medical professionals so
experts in the field of traumatic brain
injury occupational therapists
physiotherapists neurologists and also
to speak at Great length with veterans
and U.S armed forces service members
many of those who had incurred tbis but
also many who just spoke with remarkable
generosity and vulnerability about their
reasons for enlisting their experiences
while deployed
and the project of coming home and
reintegrating into their lives and
reintegrating themselves
um so I would say that I think those
conversations that research that was
foundational and was hugely
um critical to the development of the
script and my own work while prepping
the film and frankly while shooting
because of the some of the consultation
we were doing for Jen's Rehabilitation
photography and frankly into post when
I've continued to consult
um so that started for me there because
it's not my life experience
um and then
I I would add that we had the gift of
shooting this film in New Orleans where
it's set
which is a singular American city of
such Rich cultural tradition and um you
know those people that's the city that's
been through its fair share of
collective trauma and they are an
incredibly resilient
people City and their pride of place is
infectious so I think being there in the
103 degree heat
um lent a lot of let's say authenticity
to our experience a lot of our crew was
local
um I think that was meaningful for us
um and then I think
we're dealing with a cast of
tremendously astute sensitive actors who
are listening
um to their own instincts to the script
to each other
and you know I think
we're trying to drop into a very
understated and grounded register
Justine for you I'm always so impressed
when any movie gets made I don't I
honestly don't know how it happens
um because it's it's so hard
um what ended up being the biggest
challenge for you from a producerial
standpoint a particular scene and you're
not allowed to say financing because
that's the easy answer
on this one it was the apocalyptic
weather conditions that we faced yes
um
we shot the bulk of the film in 2019
but we it's complex so we plan to shoot
the film in the summer
um we had a heart out
uh which is you know a wrap day that you
can't push because Jen was getting
married
and we I think it was week two into
shooting
faced a hurricane flash floods Etc so we
knew we were gonna have to come back to
grab the week that we lost several
months later
that additional photography was pushed
three times because of the pandemic oh
so we prepped a reshoot three times
all three failed finally in the spring
of 2021 we finished the film so I would
say that oh sorry you're right early
summer summer June so I would say that
was the biggest that's amazing yeah
obstacles
I mean it looks so consistent and fluid
I would have no idea I'm glad you think
so
and Lila having directed a film now how
did directing for stage prepare you for
film directing or what were the things
that maybe caught you off guard you
didn't expect
yeah yeah you don't deal with hurricanes
in the theater usually I mean you can
actually you actually can if it's
significant enough but um your
conditions are usually more controlled
um uh
uh it was very joyful
to feel that 15 years of a certain kind
of work were very present with me in my
time on this movie and in fact and and
certain on certain basic levels that's
aspects of that are probably
um intuitive and obvious in terms of the
core collaboration with the actors the
Primacy of visual composition the core
storytelling impulses but I was actually
surprised by the ways in which
um certain parts of the theatrical
process speak to parts of the filmmaking
process in ways that were unexpected to
me I've spent most of my life in the
theater developing new plays with
writers so um working in a very
dramaturgical capacity and that
background felt very alive to me in the
editorial room constantly
um which is a place where with many
films you're dealing with questions of
structure
um you're dealing with questions of
structure and Rhythm and pacing um so I
was I think I was sort of surprised and
delighted to find unexpected parts of my
um creative history with me in new
chapters of this process
in terms of what surprised me or caught
me off guard
perhaps this is heightened I mean even
as a first-time filmmaker I think I now
know enough to know there's no such
thing as normal movie making
um but I I do think and we are not
unique at all in having had the pandemic
interrupt
our timetable
our interruptions were repeated and
significant
I think even at that I've had that not
happened this would have been a lesson
for me in the endurance of of directing
film
um you know when you direct a play the
play opens and you say goodbye
um and the actors carry the story
every night and you your contract ends
um and you know when you direct a film
it's with you every single day
um you are the through line with a
changing landscape of collaborators and
creative processes and the resilience
required in that
um
uh yeah I think you have to live that
for the first time to to Grapple with it
and both the kind of sense of
responsibility and the thrill of it well
I'm so glad you were able to make it
um sorry it took so long but I I'm also
a big believer that things happen at a
certain time for a certain reason oh
yeah yeah I mean we certainly agree and
lead into that of course it felt like a
series of disadvantages but I think we
sort of
evolve them into gifts yeah and the
movie certainly would not be what it is
now without that
bizarre and sizable Gap
well I do want everyone to spread the
word please it's such a special movie
please let people know about it
um and yeah let everyone know I was
gonna say hashtag it but I don't even
know what the hashtag is
um you guys all know how to do all that
stuff I don't have to tell you thank you
so so much for being here thank you for
being a great audience thank you guys so
much really appreciate it thank you
thank you
[Music]